hey guys down here at pax Australia with
Major Nelson what's up damn we're going
to go for a road trip you're going to
take me apparently near where your [ __ ]
I am I'm from the Gulf Coast so I
figured what better way to show you the
go oh and I've never been there really
yeah I've never been to the go let's go
digitally listen right now thanks to the
magic video games so this is Surfers
Paradise is like the place you know is
it ok sure that'd be you sure no no i
don't i i i am probably the worst call
poster that could have ever ever lived
there that's why I moved away right
before she needs now wait a minute did
you move away were you asked to leave I
was basically basically by a little
surface pretty sevens paradise there was
where I said much my time we had a time
zone uh-huh and it's two stories Masek
like a you spend a lot of time as an
arcade when you were young did what
would you favor about that game it
really depends you know back in the
early 80s it was one called battle zone
you know you put your quarters up on the
top anything any good pinball games yeah
outrun I mean the list goes on and on
yeah but those have to remember our
caves at that point they were the
precursor what is xbox live right over
the social hub for people that love
video game yes right is there any place
in Australia that you've always wanted
to go to jail no I'm a scuba diver oh
really so so you'd want to go right now
yeah Barrier Reef has glad I've never
been and I really wanted to go check
that out I don't even stupid article
about 10 years oh well yeah Wow what's
reuses nah I've always wanted to be a
scuba diver and I mean the fact that a
majority of planet Earth is underwater
Jeff is fascinating to the other you
also go down there and when you're down
there you can't be connected to your
phone their isolation II you're just
enjoying your nature yeah so I love it
that you have a slide background info I
actually went to university for
television radio film production yep so
I'm in the world of telling story I love
my narrative I love being immersed I
mean I talked a little bit about red
dead
we have one of the most extraordinary
narratives ever yeah like I gotta be
honest I've I cried at the end yeah I
mean I was like this is amazing yeah I
think you're going the wrong way haha i
was just saying what was that was the
film you are in it's about sleepers yes
and it's with Robert De Niro and Kevin
Baker so that makes your bacon number
right let you come okay make sure is
quite low why don't be too right oh
don't worry about me I'm glad you really
value I so when you are when you do that
for a drive I can jump a background
radio yeah GRU very critical of DJ's
highly clue yeah I'll in fact at night
when I go to sleep I like that music on
I can't have the radio on because my
subconscious is working why are they
playing that song yeah why did they do
that so you judge the playlist oh yeah I
draw the playlist the flow the format
everything one terrible is pot here this
would be a teleporter up okay which is
where when I was in year 7 I went to a
campaign okay and I lost my bag and I
only had one star wars shirt Alaska an
entire week when I was well get your
backpack no I shuts gone forever now at
that age that's pretty you have to wear
a one sugar yeah then we start you know
that's that's bad stuff yeah it stuck
with me over my arm I buscalo I bet
don't really understand how crazy camp
stories are and they affect you that
many years later I still think about
that when I can't sleep at night did you
have anything like that happen yeah I
went to I went to soccer football camp
okay excited I used to play soccer back
of the day and I had some of those
experiences you know yeah the atomic
wedgies all that oh well you have a
whole thing excellency you had like the
true American bro oh yeah absolutely far
that's way that experience is real
that's not not not if Alex know at all
you could get one piece of advice and
someone wants to fight me to the games
and this one is to obviously you know
learn learn what learn about the parts
of the game that fascinate you yeah you
know that as an audio guy and somebody
was in radio sound and games fascinating
debate absolutely but it's the one thing
you can't put in the screenshot showing
up I know you have and you have to
experience you know look at the things
are going to be the most impactful for
your life yep and focus on those invited
me on your white and it's appropriately
guys we're gonna see if we can actually
try that way across the ocean we're
going I've never done it before so let's
do it thank you so much you get a hand
we're going to pray about that we're
going to go selling the least I go to go